[Music]
on this sunday night
covered 19 defiance these police or
anybody else out here is nothing to tell
us that we can't go to church
those breaking the rules and the reality
check from inside canada's hospitals
are expanding they're very full fauci's
frightening warning to the us
we may see a surge upon a surge as
millions head back home this
thanksgiving weekend
plus the covet 19 economy this isn't
about how much money are you spending
this is what are you stabilizing the
federal government's long-awaited look
at the books
and helping the homeless the added
challenge during this pandemic
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
sonia diol good evening thanks very much
for joining us for the number of coveted
19 cases
is still rising rapidly across canada so
too
are the acts of defiance against
pandemic restrictions
public health orders are in place to try
and keep our hospitals from being
completely overwhelmed
many already treating record numbers of
covert 19 patients
and intensive care units are being
pushed to their limits but in places
like calgary and steinbach manitoba this
weekend
there was a complete disregard for
health measures heather eurek's west
looks at the pandemic pushback in our
top story tonight
churchgoers at steinbeck manitoba's
church of god were
defiant sunday morning lining the
highway to taking a service over
loudspeaker
as rcmp blocked the parking lot under
manitoba public health order even
drive-in services are not allowed i
believe
in god and i believe in our constitution
and i believe in our bill of rights in
canada
it's true that canadians have a right to
things like religious freedom
but during a public health emergency
those rights can be restricted
if health officials feel measures are
necessary to curb the spread of covet
19.
in places where where healthcare
resources are so strained like steinback
in manitoba you really have to have
public buy-in obviously you really do
have to have people that are following
and adhering to the guidance
a rally in calgary saturday saw several
hundred people gather in protest of
provincial restrictions
as well even as alberta doctors worry
that measures announced earlier in the
week
don't go far enough an edmonton icu
physician says
he sympathizes with protesters i
understand it
um i had to go out into the real world
for
an errand i haven't done it forever and
the relief of just pretending it wasn't
there was incredible
pretending though doesn't change reality
and the very real human cost of ignoring
the serious situation at hand
on twitter saturday dr marklin shared in
gut-wrenching detail
the heartbreaking moment he had with a
sick covet patient just before she was
put on a ventilator
he writes she catches me in a pause now
her tears come in hot streams
she clasps her phone in her hand and
lifts it up
yes you should call your son and husband
just in case
more tears now but now we are both
crying
the slow inevitable progression of this
disease allows us a little time to
actually
really be exposed to the humanity of
this and that's that's hard
made more difficult by the knowledge of
what's to come
thousands of daily new infections will
mean hundreds more will need hospital
care in a few weeks time
filling up beds that are quickly running
in short supply
heather eurex west global news calgary
well let's show you the bigger picture
of coveted 19 cases across the country
today
of the provinces and territories
reporting new case numbers
ontario had the highest number with more
than 1700 new infections
quebec has had nearly 1400. manitoba
recorded
365 new cases a similar number in
saskatchewan with 351.
there were a total 28 new cases in the
atlantic provinces today
none of it had 13 the other territories
in bc
not reporting any numbers today but
alberta
had more than 1600 cases today following
a record-breaking day yesterday
as a result alberta now has the second
highest
rate of active cases in the country 341
per 100 000 people manitoba still has
the highest rate with 659
active cases per 100 000 people
tomorrow the finance minister will
deliver a much anticipated
economic update on its pandemic finances
it is unclear exactly whether or not
this is going to look like
a full budget but it is expected to
chart a course
for the months ahead michaela couture
has more for us from ottawa
after months of demanding a full
accounting of liberal spending
conservative leader erin o'toole is
seemingly shifting his focus
my top priority is a plan for vaccines
there is no
plan for the economy if we don't have
rapid testing
and vaccines as swiftly as possible the
pandemic will likely be the central
theme of the economic update and while
the conservatives have supported the
bulk of federal relief measures
o'toole is hoping for some restraint
from the finance minister
so i want to see if she remains
in that same view that she can spend
without regard to the public finances as
long as interest rates are low
i'm hoping that's not her fiscal anchor
prime minister justin trudeau warned
last month not to expect a fiscal anchor
and some economists believe
freeland's update won't be a complete
roadmap of where the country is going
because so much is unknown some kind of
marriage
of the scenarios that we are starting to
hear about
consistently from a public health
perspective that that will color
the financial outlook the economic
statement will likely mirror
some of the themes of september's throne
speech which focused on getting more
women back into the workforce
and growing a green economy among other
things
are there going to be new investments in
long-term care in health care are there
going to be new investments in child
care some areas that
really were highlighted by this pandemic
but i think that are of interest to the
liberals in the long run
that extra spending is expected to raise
the deficit which stood at 343
billion dollars in july the last time
the government
provided a fiscal snapshot look we don't
have any options
other than spending right now we've gone
through the looking glass this isn't
about how much money are you spending
this is what are you stabilizing and if
you don't do it what are you making
worse
plenty of hard-hit industries will be
looking to this update for help
including the airlines
which have been decimated by the
pandemic as travel
essentially came to a halt sonia
michael couture in ottawa thank you very
much for that
well in the u.s today is the busiest
travel day of the year as millions of
americans head home from thanksgiving
celebrations
with so many ignoring the warning not to
travel health officials are bracing
themselves for another
deadly surge jennifer johnson has more
on the crisis ahead
as millions of americans return home
through airports and on the roads after
the thanksgiving holiday
the busiest travel day of the year
healthcare experts warned there will be
consequences
clearly in the next few weeks perhaps
even
two or three weeks down the line we may
see a surge upon a surge you know we
don't want to frighten people
but that's just the reality an estimated
7 million people traveled through u.s
airports from november 22nd to the 25th
ahead of the holiday now they are
heading back home with this advice
if you're young and you gathered you
need to be
tested about five to ten days later but
you need to assume that you're infected
health care officials fear what's coming
one doctor
offering this warning i hope
that the last moments of your life don't
look like
this because this is what you'll see at
the end of your life
if we don't start wearing masks
los angeles county officials are not
backing down as their controversial
three-week ban on public and private
gatherings
takes effect monday dead people don't
get a second chance
doctors are frustrated so many americans
are ignoring safety guidelines
like this massive illegal party busted
in new york city
as the release of a vaccine gets closer
on saturday the first doses of a vaccine
were flown from brussels to chicago
awaiting federal approval for those on
the front lines it can't come soon
enough
it's been really tough for us resources
have been stretched thin
you know the staff has been stretched
thin the white house coronavirus task
force is hoping to meet with
president-elect joe biden's
administration monday
while federal health officials vote
tuesday on who will get the vaccine
first
but it will be up to each state to make
the final decision the overwhelming
recommendation is for health care
workers to get the vaccine first
as many hospitals are overwhelmed with
cobit 19 patients
jennifer johnson global news washington
well black friday shopping is always a
part of thanksgiving celebrations in the
u.s and many canadians would usually
head south of the border
to grab some deals not being the case
this year with the borders still
close to all non-essential travel but as
tim sargent now explains
work is underway to figure out how to
reopen safely
as thousands of montrealers hit downtown
in search of black friday deals
some bargain hunters may have preferred
doing their holiday shopping
south of the border but the ongoing
closure is forcing people to stay
in their respective countries let's try
to you know
see what it is that we are going to
change but now
former quebec premier joshua is part of
a joint task force with other former
lawmakers
looking into the conditions under which
the border can eventually reopen
the task force he's part of needs to
make recommendations by march
does it mean we'll have to have a
vaccine does it mean we'll have to
produce a health certificate well we
have to have our temperature taken i
mean there's a whole host of issues of
questions
that's a question that a lot of people
who live near the border are asking
robin smith is a dual citizen who just
moved into canada to be close to her
parents
she lives in a community where the
border separates the town of stansted
quebec
and derby line vermont smith is in no
rush for the borders to reopen to
non-essential travel
my family members people i know here
they don't really want it to open either
the land border between canada and the
u.s has remained closed to non-essential
travel since march
last week the number of non-commercial
vehicles entering canada was down
92 compared to the same period last year
but commercial traffic
a different story almost 118 000 trucks
entered canada last week
a drop of only 1.8 percent compared to
2019.
trucker sean lemare favors some sort of
health check
before allowing people to cross the
border as
uh partners canada in the u.s i don't
think we're anywhere near ready
unless the infection rates drop
dramatically and quickly then the
borders will likely remain closed
through the holidays
and the hundreds of thousands of people
who normally cross on a weekly basis
will likely have to wait until well into
2021 to visit
each other's country tim's sergeant
global news montreal
there could soon be an end to the
lobster fishery dispute in nova scotia
the chief of the sebagon agardy first
nation says he's reviewing a draft
agreement from the federal government it
would allow the migmar community to
legally harvest
and sell their catch the deal also has
the potential
to be a historic recognition of treaty
rights and bring understanding
to the term moderate livelihood fishery
now all we want to do is exercise our
right and to have our
our communities out of poverty and i
think this will help bring our people's
you know standard of living
upwards and um that's what i mean for us
people don't realize
we're really doing it for and it's just
a better way of life for our people
sebagon agardy fishers launched a
moderate livelihood fishery back in
september
since then several mig more first
nations have followed suit
many non-indigenous fishers have been
critical of the move
the dispute sparked violence over the
last two months
debugging could be the first mig more
band to reach a deal
with ottawa still ahead the lucky escape
nothing short of a miracle
after a formula one driver is left
trapped in a burning car
he's lucky to walk away f1 driver roman
grosjean hit the wall at full speed
during the opening lap
of bahrain's grand prix the force
cutting his car
in half and wedging him between the
wreck and the barrier
miraculously he escaped with only minor
burns to his hands and ankles
reigning champion lewis hamilton who
went on to win said the risk
drivers take is no joke and the good
outcome is a credit to how
safety standards have improved
saskatchewan's health authority has
declared a covert 19
outbreak among a teenage hockey team
nine players and one coach
on the warm and wildcats have tested
positive as a result the entire team
along with their most recent opponents
are now having to self-isolate as of
friday team and group sports in the
province were suspended
athletes under the age of 18 can still
practice in small groups
but those taking part have to stay at
least three metres away from each other
and wear a mask a big question tonight
about how much longer the nfl season is
set to last as more teams are being hit
hard by covid19
and players are having to sideline to
quarantine
the denver broncos are facing new
orleans saints without any quarterbacks
after three broncos players were
identified as high risk
close contact in a statement addressed
to all teams the nfl commissioner
confirmed that a number of staff and
players
celebrated the thanksgiving holiday with
out-of-town guests
all team facilities are being ordered to
close for the next two days
to slow the spread of the virus a
woman's made history
in power 5 football it's the highest
level of college football in the us
happy thanksgiving what a day
sarah fuller ran out for vanderbilt
university yesterday becoming the first
woman to play in the competition
fuller kicked off to start the second
half against missouri
the 21 year old soccer player from texas
was actually called in after
vanderbilt lost a number of players due
to covet 19
restrictions the best part that she wore
the phrase
play like a girl on her helmet
still ahead the struggle of grappling
both health and homelessness during this
pandemic
and those stepping in to help
you're watching global national
[Music]
welcome back well the pandemic has had
an impact on all canadians but it's hit
those on a low income
especially hard there's now a growing
concern that the number of homeless
people in canada
may go up it's estimated at least 235
000 canadians experience homelessness in
a year
35 000 experience homelessness on any
given night
global's catherine ward now has the
story of a man from toronto who is
struggling to get the help he needs
i didn't go to the hospital i couldn't i
would have been dead that emergency was
the wake-up call
jimmy evans never expected jimmy had
been in and out of the shelter system
for years since arriving in toronto from
prince edward island
things were starting to get better he
managed to secure affordable housing but
on that day
in 2017 years of hard living made it
clear
jimmy was very sick jimmy was suffering
from end stage
liver disease doctors told him they
didn't know how long he would live
they said a year to two years two
doctors came in
and then they said you realize
in the past five months she had two
heart attacks according to the city of
toronto jimmy is one of more than 8 000
people who fall on the homeless spectrum
for the last two years his care has
fallen through the cracks as he missed
appointments
and doctors sometimes had a hard time
finding him for follow-ups
this past summer jimmy was referred to
the palliative education and care for
the homeless
or peach program started in 2014 the
program is one of only a handful in
canada
that works with people on the homeless
spectrum who are in need of end-of-life
care
dr dasani is one of the physicians he
says since the pandemic the peach
program is seeing double the number of
patients
what kovitt has kind of done is made the
safety net that supported
people from moving towards more
homelessness even weaker because of that
we are seeing more people who are
experiencing street homelessness
we're seeing more people who are losing
their housing covert 19 has created
new challenges people who are living on
the streets
and experiencing homelessness previously
had supports
in say drop-ins or respites or various
shelters
and many of these places are now closed
since the start of the pandemic many
doctors have moved to virtual consults
the practice
adds an additional barrier for these
patients if you get a new diagnosis of
cancer and you're living in the shelter
system
and trying to coordinate access to
something like a specialist appointment
when
all the specialists are using phones for
their for their visits
if you don't have a phone then how are
you supposed to get to those visits the
beach team
helps fill in those gaps leanne trevors
works as the group's health navigator
she arranges transportation for checkups
renews prescriptions
and coordinates meals solving whatever
patient problems arise
we never want to push to say this is
what you need we'd rather ask them what
do you need and how can we support you
since joining the peach program in the
summer jimmy has not missed a single
appointment
now he has new dreams of going back home
to pei
to see the ocean one more time go deep
sea fishing
where you can't see lands and jump off
the boat and go for a swim
future is the future is going to be what
it is catherine ward
global news toronto
up next montreal's new approach for
providing winter wars
to those struggling to find it
maybe
well december is just days away and the
weather is getting colder for canada's
homeless population
it makes an already difficult life even
more challenging
especially when cities don't always see
eye to eye on the methods on how to keep
the homeless warm such as setting up
camps in parks
but as mike armstrong explains montreal
is taking a new approach on how to get
people off the streets
this camp popped up over the summer
wedged along the side of a busy
boulevard
thousands pass it morning noon and night
the people in it
say that's why the city wants them out
they want us to disappear homelessness
is showing off in montreal
and they don't like it to be showing
at its peak the camp was home to about
125 people
that's dropped week by week there are
only a couple of dozen left
the city has an outreach program
explaining to the campers
there are options if they don't want to
stay here the entire winter then we
offer them to come to the shelter
one thing being offered this week is
storage the city's promising to pack up
possessions and give them back to people
in the spring
there are also 700 new beds being made
available this downtown hotel is being
turned into a shelter
and there's a new city bus that's going
to be making the rounds
offering a chance to warm up and another
chance at outreach
that's what it's all about to make sure
that they know that we're there to
support
the city is also trying something new
it's pairing a police officer with a
social worker creating a team
dedicated to the homeless population
right now even the people pushing it
say it's likely not enough but it's a
start
i think it's probably the future of
policing is
is being tried right here this winter
and that's a good thing
the challenge continues to be getting
people off the streets
if they want to stay that can't be so
late
over the month some have been preparing
for winter this man gives his name is
jacques
and insists he's ready who are they to
think
what i need i know what i need i don't
need nothing
except peace respect and
liberty the problem is that jacques has
a nice place and then uh heater and all
that
but the guy besides them do not but he's
following jacques
now the goal is to get as many people
out of this camp as possible before the
temperature drops to -30 and -40 in the
coming months
basically before it's too late and lives
are in danger
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm sonia dion we leave you
tonight with a friendly blue dragon
it's been lazing around in the saskatoon
snow the woman behind this incredible
snow sculpture usually makes one on her
driveway every winter
but decided to go extra big to make her
neighbors happy
this year donna freezing is back at the
anchor desk tomorrow thank you very much
for watching
have a great night